i then went to a place of like okay i
want to get to know this woman i really
want to know what's going on totally
different than watching it like oh look
at that train wreck
it's like wait why was it why why did it
all happen and this is why we made this
show
this is an inspiring and inspiring step
forward this isn't just my job this is
who i am
anybody who doubts my company
doubts me first of all congrats on the
show i i just binged the heck out of it
and watched all the screeners in about
seven hours and didn't get up it's so
good oh god did you really
i really did all of them
it is well you know i was really into
this the podcast and the documentary and
all that were you two both into it and
if not like how much research did you do
into all that and the court documents
and everything to prepare i mean
i ate all of it way before i knew that
this was a project that i would be
involved in and then i ate it all again
and then we were given these big
document these digital files to
look through and
i and i and i got the deposition tapes
those were gold for me i just rewatched
them over and over again i can i know
them
word for word
which i never thought i'd experience in
my entire life but it was amazing for me
i have to ask do you have a favorite
quote from the depositions or something
you used over and over again to like get
into her character oh uh actually the
thing i the thing i used over and over
again to get into character
was the maria shriver interview and
she's like uh i was
no i i it's devastating i feel
devastated
that
we
did not
catch and fix these issues faster
like that the way she
that was so
heavy and um i don't know why that was a
thing that was really important um
maybe because she showed an emotion
uh
sure yeah it was something
it was definitely something and it was
really helpful um it was defiance i
think yeah really
if i'm not that it matters really but
whatever it was it was it was heavy and
it definitely affected it was impactful
but when she's on stage you know and
really happy and talking to her about
their noses that was what i would watch
when i was on set and i would actually
have one like this
one of these the rpas olivia would hold
her phone out um just so it was ready
she's like
and at one point i was like oh no i'm
fine i'm just i'm okay but it was really
funny she was
i cuz they knew that it was oh it's
always it's helpful right this
technology is ten years away your idea
is impossible so you just keep trying do
or do not there is no try
that's yoda
okay
wow never enough and never enough but
but as if i of course we came at it very
as an actor playing her i then went to a
place of like okay i want to get to know
this woman i really want to know what's
going on
liz merryweather wrote these amazing
scripts okay
i totally agree this isn't you know a
lot of compassion totally different than
watching it like oh look at that train
wreck
it's like wait why was it why why did it
all happen and this is why we made this
show i can't give them one reason to
doubt me it's not even close to working
yet
what are we gonna show at the demo we're
gonna tell them that we don't have a
working prototype
right
no i mean that's the it's as much as we
took in you know it's it's still that
question of who who were these people
because we didn't know that much about
them personally we still
right naveen what did you go to i mean i
know all those text messages between
these two got released did you two look
to those to kind of get this chemistry
it was already too late though i mean
we'd already made a decision very early
on um on day one actually about the
depth and the intensity of uh their
relationship i felt that he was besotted
with her
and for me was there was a romantic
aspect to the story how far are you
prepared to go if you love someone what
do you prepare to do i know what you did
at the demo
was an inspiring step forward
don't tell anyone else i'm going to
protect you
do you two feel like you know them now
or like like if they were in front of
you right now what questions would you
want to ask them
let's be really anxious um
uh some uh so many how many stupid jobs
t-shirts did you own
um
i mean there's so many questions i i
you know i know they don't speak anymore
apparently but like i i don't know i i i
always wondered if they ever wanted to
get married or like
if there was always an endgame or if
there was always
yeah i would want to ask him if do you
truly believe that she loved you
do you believe that
she loved you i love how much you two
went into the love story of it because
again that's this other whole other
layer it's so important because people
are like nah they were together like it
was just people didn't seem to
understand why and it's just like love
funds away
but they really there was an innocence
to their meeting it's not like they they
were like oh you're into that i'm into
that let's get into this
it's like they had feelings for each
other they felt safe with each other and
there's nothing better than feeling safe
with somebody
especially when you meet them in
beijing and you guys speak the same
literal same language like he's actually
he was trying he was actually learning
mandarin as well and she wanted to she
was taking it very seriously it's just
it all there's so much context in this
that is so necessary for fans of of her
story of
their nose you know
people will trust the technology
because they will trust you
do you hope they watch the show and if
they do what do you hope their takeaways
are oh um
oh my god yeah you know you know i
um
yeah
do i i don't think i hope anything i
just
we show them as human beings
that's kind of all anybody really wants
i think without judgment
yeah
yeah i mean listen it doesn't have to be
completely right but we definitely tried
and
it's kind of an amazing story and it can
be highly educational too um
but it's just a story you know
for the sake of our show and yeah if
they watch it they watch it you know
it's we can't really kind of think on
those terms michaela was just raving
about you amanda and saying wow she
better get some awards love for this
performance how would that feel to get
recognized oh i mean beyond it's like
i've only
for the first time in my life last year
got to
dance in those circles and talk about my
performance
instead of like the whole picture and it
was
it was actually really
really nice and it created like a
different kind of foundation and
um
sure that would be great but i could
totally live without it
and it absolutely isn't the reason
uh i did it so
you know
uh well you're incredible
people watch it and then if they watch
it i'm just profoundly grateful she did
do it
me too i'm we're finally
you were already he was already signed
on
like
who's playing sunny oh noob ninjas has
been detached to play sonny for a decade
i was like
awesome that's it we don't have to find
us any
we're good we haven't seen a single
contract she is lying to you
you're in over your head i'm going to
lose everything
no i'm fine everything's fine
[Music]
you